how much of a challenge  in a car tonight  he's good financially but I was on my  own I was listening to them to my my  fellow actors then saying I wasn't alone  at all I just was reading an autocue and  listening to my friends there's been  lots of talk about your topping peoples  list for the next Bond I would I  wouldn't imagine I was so I think Daniel  Craig is pretty much set for an extra  couple of films as new  you've just been filming Mad Max as well  have that been going  that's great it's a big old piece  there's a big mouth of a beast so I'm  off out there next week to to to do some  reshoots whatnot reaches that you were  doing more building building more Mad  Max is even more spectacular possible  something for us all to look for to next  year absolutely yeah absolutely